thirty players back in their place of
work and a boost for our football loving
nation and we've worked really hard with
football authorities police and medical
experts to get to this point but we do
need fans to play their part too so
please look after your fellow fans and
your communities by watching from home
to keep the home advantage support from
home now all 92 remaining Premier
League's will be shown playing Premier
League games we've shown live on TV and
I'm delighted that I and others managed
to work hard to get a third of them on
free-to-air channels Friday will be the
first to free-to-air with Norwich V
Southampton then an important day on
Saturday that will be when we've had the
first ever Premier League game on the
BBC followed by the Merseyside derby
again free-to-air on the Sunday and
there'll be extended highlights of all
the games free to air so you won't have
to miss a single goal our sports men and
women have set some incredible examples
during this pandemic using their
profiles to support worthwhile causes
across the United Kingdom
England's men and women cricket teams
have donated half a million pounds
towards charitable causes rugby league's
Cheshire Bank West Bank Bears have
delivered food and parcels to the
elderly and of course the England and
Manchester United Football and Marcus
Rushford has made the front and the back
pages for the very best of reasons
highlighting the struggles facing many
families during this difficult time but
that is of course
[Music]
what happened in the last two weeks
absolutely has motivated me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]